router Idris prepares her family's
launch of corn flour and wild shrubs
it's the first and last meal of the day
the wild plants help a lot sometimes we
go entire days with nothing to eat
except that
router says they are lucky many of the
families will go to bed with empty
stomachs tonight
the United Nations is running out of
food for these refugees already it's
quite a struggle to ensure every family
receives one meal a day now officials
are saying that unless harp arrives by
the end of October people will starve
this is how much stock is left in the
world food programs Warehouse in the
capital in Germany
it's what more than a million Sudanese
refugees currently depend on
if we don't really assist those people
we are it's really going to be
catastrophic
because people are dying people will
continue to die at another Pace the
coping mechanism of those refugees are
just terrible
the rainy season has worsened the
situation with flooded roads making it
difficult to deliver the little Aid
available
on the other hand the weather has slowed
the influx of new arrivals but still
there is a major impact on the local
population
the oriented situation themselves as
well because water and sanitation and
food is the same forever and they have
to share we are trying to cover as many
needs as we can as I said we are only
funded up to 27 percent of of our needs
the same is with other U.N agencies that
are supporting Refugee response in the
Eastern of chart
authorities say the slower pace of
arrivals is only temporary and they
expect another 200 000 people to cross
into the country by the end of the year
this could push the population of
Sudanese refugees in child to more than
1.2 million including the roughly 600
000 displaced by earlier conflicts in
West Darfur the United Nations says it
will put additional pressure on eight
operations already struggling to keep up
with the increasing number of people in
need how many degrees Al Jazeera address
on the charge Sudan border
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera